You're gonna say one simple sentence to him...
...and he's gonna give you the package.
You're gonna say, "Elephants can swim."
Can you swim?
No. Are you listening?
Yeah, I'm listening.
Elephants can swim.
What?
Oh my God.
Do you see the hot dog stand behind you?
I need you to go buy a hot dog.
Those hot dogs are like, $14, man.
I see the man on the bridge.
Walk up towards him and say, "You have something for me".
Are you serious?
Yeah, I don't know man, some...
Believe me, it's not about the hot dog.
You're not gonna eat the hot dog and the hot dog isn't even real.
It's what's in the hot dog.
I promise, you will thank me at the end of this.
Yeah, 'cause I don't usually eat pork.
You're gonna walk up to that man and just say, "Great day for a hot dog".
But do not give him the hot dog.
Great day for a...
It's a great day for a hot dog, huh?
That's excellent work Adam, let him clear.
Let him clear.
If something happens, it's gonna happen now...
...and it's gonna happen to him.
He didn't take the hot dog.
I've still got the hot dog.
No, I told you not to give him the hot dog.
Now, walk away.
Walk away.
What is this?
That manila envelope is the hottest potato you've ever held in your hand.